congratulations on becoming world
champion joy relief shy of first
feelings
no i'm
relieved of course
and
you know it's hard to uh
it's hard to
feel that great joy when
there was the situation was so
comfortable
to begin with but
you know i'm
happy with the
with a very good performance overall
you put pressure on you and you provoked
him to make mistakes four decisive wins
we know you're quite critical of
yourself but this match that must be
pretty hard to do
um
sure so you can point at
things you could have done differently
in every game of course
but
overall overall i'm happy with my my
play very proud of my effort in the in
the sixth game uh and that sort of laid
the foundation
for um for everything um
because um you know the the game the
match is probably the final score is
probably
a bit more lopsided than
it could have been but
that's the way i think um some of the
other matches also could have gone if
i've gotten an
uh if i gotten a lead
magnus this is your fifth title where
does it rank amongst all your world
championship quick trees
no it's hard to say the last one is
always in in a way
the
the sweetest but i'm just happy to have
one and finally i remember chennai the
first time you became the world champion
you were thrown into the swimming pool
what's the plan for tonight for
celebrations
i'm focused on the game
all right congrats